Le nazisme naît au lendemain de la
Première Guerre mondiale.
Hitler en devient le chef de file
et le Parti national socialiste,
et bientôt le principal mouvement
de l'extrême droite allemande.
Il accueille tous ceux qui,
nostalgiques de l'Empire anticommuniste,
et antisémite, n'ont pas accepté
que le nouveau régime politique,
la République de Weimar,
signe le traité de Versailles,
qui attribue à l'Allemagne
la responsabilité de la Grande Guerre.
Au milieu des années 20,
l'économie allemande se redresse.
La jeune république allemande
résiste mieux à ses détracteurs.
Les partis qui acceptent le
régime parlementaire se renforcent.
C'est alors que le krach boursier de
1929 plonge le monde dans le marasme.
En 1932, le pays compte
6 millions de chômeurs.
Cette crise débouche sur une
montée du fascisme en Europe.
Les partis totalitaires vont
exploiter la peur issue de la crise.
En 1932, aux élections allemandes, n***
et communistes obtiennent 53% des voix.
Devant la montée des communistes, une partie
de l'électorat voit en Hitler un recours.
La droite traditionnelle
veut utiliser sa popularité,
pour instaurer un régime
autoritaire et éradiquer le communisme.
Le parti d'Hitler devient
le deuxième parti d'Allemagne,
derrière le Parti socialiste.
L'engrenage est lancé.
En janvier 1933, Adolf Hitler devient,
par des voies légales, chancelier du Reich.
Dans la nuit du 30 janvier, les troupes
de choc des SA défilent devant leur Führer,
maître de l'Allemagne, Hitler peut mettre
en œuvre sa révolution nationale socialiste.
Goebbels déclare : "Nous allons enfin
mettre de l'ordre dans cette porcherie."
En effet, en quelques semaines
se met en place un régime totalitaire.
Les opposants sont muselés,
les libertés publiques supprimées,
les partis et les syndicats dissous.
Le 1ᵉʳ juillet 1933, le Parti national
socialiste est proclamé parti unique.
Les SS, à l'origine
garde prétorienne d'Hitler,
prend le contrôle de toute
la police allemande,
et mène la répression contre
les démocrates dirigés par Himmler,
les SS forment une élite sélectionnée,
véritable bras armés du nazisme.
Les SS s'efforcent de mettre en
place un modèle d'homme nouveau,
conforme aux critères biologiques
du nazisme, qui prône l'inégalité des races.
Au sommet, la pureté de
la race aryenne et en bas,
les autres qui la polluent, dont les Juifs.
Dans Mein Kampf, le livre
écrit par Hitler en 1924,
il définit les Juifs comme
des êtres au sang impur.
L'antisémitisme est bien un
des fondements majeurs du nazisme.
Le régime hitlérien veut
en effet créer une société pure,
débarrassée des individus jugés
débiles et de la race inférieure.
Dès leur arrivée au pouvoir, les nazis
excluent progressivement les Juifs,
de la communauté et tentent
de les faire fuir.
En septembre 1935, les lois de Nuremberg
font des Juifs des citoyens de seconde zone.
Lors du pogrom de la Nuit
de Cristal en novembre 1938,
7 000 magasins juifs sont pillés,
les synagogues incendiées.
Les Juifs sont expropriés, pourchassés,
arrêtés. Dans les camps de concentration,
ils rejoignent les ennemis du régime.
Les camps de concentration sont le
prolongement logique de l'idéologie nazie,
basée sur l'exclusion.
Dès le 21 mars 1933, deux mois
après l'arrivée au pouvoir d'Hitler,
un camp de concentration
s'ouvre à Dachau, près de Munich.
Un autre suit à Orianenburg,
dans la banlieue de Berlin.
Puis viendront Buchenwald,
à côté de Weimar 1937.
Flossenbürg en Bavière 1938.
Ravensbrück. Camp de femmes
près de Berlin 1939.
Dorugamon à côté de Hambourg 1940, Gross-
rosen et Mauthausen en Autriche 1938.
Puis le Struthof après
l'annexion de l'Alsace.
L'araignée concentrationnaire tisse sa toile,
sur tous les territoires
contrôlés par le Reich.
Une trentaine de camps, auxquels sont
rattachés des dizaines de camps de travail,
lesquels concentration lager,
sont à l'origine destinés à
enfermer les opposants politiques,
communistes, socialistes,
démocrates et à les broyer.
Les mesures disciplinaires
sont sadiques, bestiales.
Les SS qui ont la haute main
sur l'administration des camps,
mêlent aux politiques des asociaux,
c'est-à-dire dire les droits communs,
les criminels, les tziganes, les handicapés
mentaux et physiques, les homosexuels,
et bien entendu les Juifs. Dans les camps,
une hiérarchie des détenus se met en place,
favorisée par les SS,
triangle rouge des politiques,
vert pour les droits communs, rose
pour les homosexuels, jaune pour les Juifs.
Au fil des ans, les internés,
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
à la veille de la guerre,
deviennent un vivier
économique pour le Reich.
Les détenus forment une main d'œuvre
gratuite pour les industriels et les mines.
Les camps les plus durs sont
édifiés à proximité des carrières,
comme à Mathausen, où les esclaves
extraient la pierre nécessaire,
aux grands travaux hitlériens.
Après le déclenchement de la guerre,
et la mobilisation des ouvriers
allemands dans la Wehrmacht,
la dimension économique du système
concentrationnaire devient plus évidente.
Les camps de concentration ne
servent plus seulement la répression,
mais fournissent les bras indispensables
aux usines d'armement.
Cette main d'œuvre exploitable sans limites,
meurt sous les coups, meurent d'épuisement,
meurt de maladie.
À la fin de 1941, Hitler
décide la mise en route,
e ce que les nazis appellent
la solution finale.
À la conférence de Wannsee en janvier
1942, dans la banlieue de Berlin,
la liquidation des Juifs d'Europe
est planifiée et rationalisée.
À côté des camps de la mort lente, les
nazis ouvrent dans le plus grand secret,
des camps de mise à mort immédiate.
On passe de la persécution à la liquidation,
des camps de concentration
aux camps d'extermination.
C'est en Pologne que s'ouvrent
4 d'entre eux pour les Juifs,
à Chelmno, près de Lodz, on
a recours à des camions à gaz,
dès décembre 1941 pour
asphyxier les juifs polonais.
Belzec, construit en
pleine forêt près de Lublin,
est mise en service en mars 1942.
Plus de 500 000 Juifs y sont
gazés par monoxyde de carbone.
Sobibor, où périssent 200 000 Juifs,
fonctionne à partir du printemps 1942,
à partir de juillet 1942,
les Juifs de Varsovie,
de Lublin sont déportés à Treblinka.
Dans une dizaine de chambres à gaz,
750 000 Juifs sont assassinés.
À partir de 1942, Himmler décide la
construction à côté du camp d'Auschwitz I,
d'une véritable usine de mort à Birkenau.
Au début de fermes ont été
aménagées enb chambres à gaz.
Mais devant l'arrivée massive des convois,
ces installations artisanales
se révèlent insuffisantes.
4 ensemble chambres à gaz crématoires
sont construits et entrent en service.
La firme Ig-farben fournit le Zyklon B.
À Birkenau sont acheminés les convois de
Juifs de France, d'Allemagne, des Pays-Bas,
de Belgique, de Grèce et au
cours de l'été 1944, de Hongrie.
Au total, plus d'un million de Juifs
d'Europe sont exterminés à Birkenau.
Au moment même où des
photos aériennes d'Auschwitz,
parviennent à l'état-major allié,
la découverte du premier camp d'extermination
confirme les pires prévisions.
L'armée rouge entre
en effet le 23 juillet 1944,
dans le camp de Maïdanek,
abandonné par les SS.
Une partie du camp a été détruite,
mais la chambre à gaz est intacte.
Des montagnes de chaussures, de lunettes,
de valises témoignent de l'extermination
de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de juifs polonais.
Quelques mois plus tard, le 23 novembre,
l'armée américaine entre dans
le camp du Struthof, en Alsace,
seul camp de concentration
sur le territoire français.
En janvier 1945, l'Armée rouge
arrive dans le complexe d'Auschwitz,
dont la plupart des déportés ont
été évacués 10 jours auparavant,
dans des conditions d'épouvante.
Trois mois plus tard, les Alliés
libèrent en quelques semaines,
du 4 avril Ohrdruf au 5 mai Mathausen.
Les camps de concentration sur
le territoire du Troisième Reich.
Le monde entier découvre la barbarie nazie.